Building something that looks great in the visual layout editor is the easy
part. You also need to consider different screens and orientations. As you
begin to layout your UI, there's a temptation to build it pixel perfect for
the device you happen to be using at the time. This is reinforced by
the fact that your apps window doesn't generally change size while it's running.
So you can't just grab the lower i-corner and grow and
shrink your app to see how it behaves. But if you've ever developed for
the web or desktop, you know this static approach is a bad idea.
When Android first launched, HVGA 480 by 320 resolution screens were standard.
As we began exploring how to build engaging user experiences on those devices,
we could use absolute layouts to define the exact location of each
screen element. But within a year, the first WVGA Android phones were released.
And now Android runs on everything from phones to phablet's, tablet's, TVs and
wearables with any screen size, resolution and aspect ratio you can imagine.
So, just like desktop or web where you might use panels or
CSS, your Android UI needs to scale based on the screen it's running within,
which is why absolute layout was deprecated.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
In favor of layouts like LinearLayout, RelativeLayout and
GridLayout, they can dynamically resize and
adapt to any screen, following the principles of responsive design.